everybody was kind of doing their own
homework and building their characters
and and getting into getting into the
role you'd be shocked to find out how
much how much training went into making
this movie
embolism behind the little details and
of course the things that you'd think
were practical but were actually
achieved with CGI let's talk about it
it's amazing to be a part of such a such
a massive movie franchise such a
successful film number one every shot of
black panther suit is 100 CGI they had
an outfit that Chadwick Boseman would
wear on set but to make sure the visuals
were consistent every frame of his suit
in the film is digitally rendered this
one was a combination where we wanted to
use a live-action performance and
obviously the facial performance from
the actor they used Chadwick's
performance and mannerisms to blend real
life with CGI and did a lot of
fine-tuning behind the scenes to get the
neck deformation to be accurate to make
sure that the blending of the live
action actor and the CG lined up number
two hours were spent in the chair for
this movie Michael B Jordan spent two
and a half hours in the makeup chair
transforming into Eric killmonger it
took a team of four makeup artists to
apply individually sculpted silicone
molds to his upper body he was covered
in 3 000 prosthetic dots that had to be
carefully applied and Blended to his
skin tone number three
tons of beautiful CGI brought this movie
to life what we did on the day was we
shot Chadwick rising up onto a couple of
foam blocks you'll notice that what was
actually in the background during the
shooting was completely different from
what we see on screen in the background
Sky you know CG grass and distant
mountains all of the actual plane
wreckage no number four the cast trained
for months to learn how to fight to
prepare for their roles they obviously
did months of weapon training and
learned multiple fighting styles ranging
from Judo Jujitsu and capoeira how else
would they have been able to perform all
of their own stunts Chadwick Boseman was
already trained in martial arts so it
wasn't that difficult for him to pick up
some additional skills Michael B Jordan
was used to performing intense scenes
from his role in Creed but had to get
through the learning curve of mastering
these difficult fighting styles in the
casino scene you can see all of their
hard work and training on full display
number five this one took a lot of takes
we had to float a movie up on a cable
rig imagine the camera here and a big
cable rig they wanted to do this
sequence all in one take but that proved
to be pretty impossible so they settled
for doing little bits at a time
there's no green screen here no no you
know this is all happening live and
direct that's actually Lupita's hand on
the top right corner taking aim as they
send the movi up to complete the shot
this is a CG explosion here on this
light to get the glass kind of flying
the entire sequence and this shot in
particular was one of the most difficult
to capture on camera but oh so worth it
number six naturally there were a lot
the cast has So Much Chemistry that
during the making of the film there were
a ton of onset laughs jokes impromptu
dance moves and freestyling in between
takes if you check out their blooper
reel you'll see things falling off the
wall doors getting stuck and major
vehicle malfunctions there's also this
incredibly touching moment between
Chadwick Boseman and Angela Bassett that
really shows how much love the two
shared on and off the set
number seven there weren't as many
extras on set as you would think a
digital double is a digitally rendered
version of an actor or performer there's
some blue screen coverage in the back
that would allow us to isolate the the
background extras that we had fighting
it in the background there were far
fewer physical extras in the scenes
where they could help it in order to
fill up these larger scenes they
utilized digital Renditions of
characters and put them in the
background we went through and added in
dozens of background Digi doubles in
order to make the the fight scene feel
much more expansive number eight a huge
part of the Black Panther lore the Dora
melange are an army of fierce women who
move is one and serve as personal
security to the king and the royal
family the Dora melange were cast from a
particular pool of performers including
stunt women and Broadway dancers the
creators of the film wanted each
individual member to have unique
individual skills that they brought to
the table
number nine the cast did the majority of
their own stunts the actors had to
participate in a black panther boot camp
to prepare them for all the physical
work the film required the cast and the
stunt team practiced to the sound of
African drums played by musician Jabari
Exum so that their movements would match
the musical quality that's found in many
african-based martial arts Daniel kaluya
even learned how to ride a horse so he
could be prepared to simulate riding
wakabi's armored rhino
number 10. 25
000 cubic feet of foam were used on the
set of warrior Falls ranging from 120
feet by 75 feet wide and 36 feet tall
construction took over four months to
complete the set was modeled after the
rocks in the oribi gorge in South Africa
though all the Rocks were actually foam
to keep the performers safe the
production crew had the challenge of
creating a surface that was rough enough
so people wouldn't slip while performing
Barefoot but also soft enough that it
didn't hurt when they fell the
production team also engineered a fully
functional waterfall and pool that
contained over 125
000 gallons of water piping through the
set at 30 000 gallons per minute
number 11. there's a lot of symbolism
that's easy to miss let's go back to the
casino scene for a minute there's a lot
of motifs um about um femininity and
especially black femininity here in this
scene Lupita nyongo is wearing a green
dress that was actually 3D printed by
the costume designer specifically for
this scene a lot of African symbolism
here
is drawn in lines and box and boxer Paws
around shapes you'll also notice that
there was a big emphasis on the wakandas
having natural hair what we notice about
okoye's character in this scene is her
red and gold dress and the gold is um is
kind of a ranking system did you notice
that no one else in the scene is wearing
red or green
flag is
is our red black and green number 12.
this one wasn't a Digi double
and I was a real fault you know I was
really going from the Second Story I'm
down to a pad here took a lot of prairie
there that was one of the
new they wanted to get from the very
beginning they they captured it first
thing that day if we can get this right
you know it'll set the tone for the rest
of the film director Ryan coogler had a
model of the set 3D printed and sitting
on his desk the whole time he was in
prep he used action figures to plan out
each character's blocking
number 13. real dedication went into the
music behind the film Black Panther's
composer Ludwig Goranson actually
traveled to Africa for inspiration in
his interview with pitchfork he talks
about how the music in Africa is so
different from anywhere else in the
world music from Africa is a language it
has a purpose you don't just play music
for people to hear every rhythm is
written for a specific reason for a
ceremony for the king
number 14. playing killmonger is no easy
feat Michael B Jordan was praised for
his performance but after the movie
wrapped Michael couldn't shake the dark
headspace he was in after being in
Eric's Shoes for so long I was by myself
isolating myself I spent a lot of time
alone I figured Eric killmonger his
childhood growing up was pretty lonely
he didn't have a lot of people he could
talk to about this place called wakanda
that didn't exist after the movie was
finished Michael was still isolated and
sitting in killmonger's headspace it got
to the point where he needed the help of
a therapist to move past all the
emotions he was feeling
number 15.
clearly Michael Dove deep into the mind
of killmonger
he went so deep that he actually kept a
diary filled with killmonger's backstory
and memories that he made up it began
with his very first memory and ended
with the first page of the Black Panther
script that wasn't the only book that
was created either production designer
Hannah beechler created a 515 page book
that detailed the Topography of wakanda
its history and the religion of its
people
black panther couldn't have been brought
to life without this Stellar cast the
Larger than Life digital effects and the
Kenai of the director what was your
favorite scene in the movie